yann toujours à l'heure toujours à
l'heure toujours en vie le temps c'est
de l'argent
le retard c'est du plomb dans la
cervelle j'imagine que tu es pas venu
jusqu'ici pour me parler métaux précieux
qu'est ce que tu veux une mission encore
une
et pour celles ci j'ai besoin d'une
équipe en or une foule est meilleur j'ai
ça représente bruce mcalister expert en
explosifs et le crès ni le druide un
génie de l'informatique
john carter spécialiste des arts
martiaux équivalent buford exprès en
sport de combat mais c'est un peu la
même chose que celui d'avoir est dit
qu'une seule acrobates accompli andrew
bauer extrêmement agaçant extrêmement
agaçant c'est à dire les zones aux yeux
de dénis jackson perlman le troc fondu
d'armes à feu merci blandas ferguson qui
tape dans ses mains
j'adore ce mec aille carlton qu'on
écoute jamais non c'est pas con et stan
paterson qui manipule le temps dans le
temps qui me manipule le temps qu'ils
manipulent le temps qu'ils manipulent le
temps et c'est super chiant donc il va
arrêter le chauffard patrick hyper
nerveux
enrique leblanc expert en me martin
standford spécialiste des guillemets
avec les doigts oui enfin spécialistes
alexandro ramirez tireurs à l'arc hors
pair non c'est parce que elles sont gros
ils il est malade donc c'est moi qui le
remplace greg barker experts au
camouflage
là pour le coup c'est super parce que
vraiment on voit rien de la part des
mois
non mais derek il a dit des reds tu
t'appelles derek peut-être c'est par ina
écoute tu n'écoutes rien on peut
enchaîner deux aînés il est pas mort les
noms c'est parce qu'il est immortel
bieber il meurt il revient ok vous
demandez pourquoi vous garder parce
qu'il est quand même très agaçant passé
pour sa part dont c'est parce que tout à
l'heure je vende inquiète c'est cool
merci à lyster donovan qui voit dans le
futur oui d'ailleurs allez-y mollo parce
que sinon je veux plus voir grand chose
franck à 1000 férus de pilotage franck a
fait pipi trenque répit oui bon enrique
leblanc experts m'ordonnant [ __ ] stop
c'est ça ton équipe alors ce sont les
meilleurs oui enfin les meilleurs dagen
toits rouges mocassins nickel je vous
avais prévenus qu'on allait pouvoir
grand chose
je vous laisse une dernière chance on en
sait qu'on en finisse
alors juste qu'on en finisse avec quoi